My name is Rob Melrose,
and I graduated from Princeton in 1992.
I majored in English, Program Five, drama ...
and I also have a certificate
in the program of theater and dance.
My name is Paige Rogers.
I am a 1989 graduate of Princeton University.
I also have the same degree, Program Five,
theater and dance, English major.
I was at public school as a young person,
and there was a wonderful
artist-in-residence program
One artist brought in a painting
by Rene Magritte.
I just got so excited about surrealism
and later on in life I asked teachers
who wrote plays like these paintings,
Magritte and Dali. That kind of set me off
on my life-long journey
of experimental theater.
I was an in-coming freshman
and Paige was a returning senior,
and of course everybody got real excited
because they knew Paige was in theater.
Oh, this is great, this is great, you
got to meet Paige, you got to meet Paige.
Then here he comes it's like
I want to know about theater.
I said, "Oh yeah, yeah, okay, let's talk
about theater," and I'm like,
"Eh, ugh, cute freshman."
I just didn't take him seriously at all.
Because I was a senior
I was deeply embarrassed
to be dating this freshman.
I really was.
We were only dating about two weeks
when we realized we should get married.
We're going to get married and let's
have a, we're going to have a child.
We never wavered and we never broke up.
After my sophomore year we ran
the Princeton summer theater together.
He directed Twelfth Night
and I was in it.
I directed Larry Shoe the Nerd
and he played the nerd,
and we had a absolutely terrible time.
It was a total failure. It was brutal.
The fact that our relationship survived ...
If we'd had crystal ball saying
this is what you're going to do
for the rest of your life. I think we
would have run screaming from one another.
For me, Michael Cadden was my JP advisor.
Alan Mockler was my senior thesis advisor
and I did a production of Miss Julie.
They were both very, very influential.
My senior thesis was a production of
The Seagull, and I also
was the publicity manager and then
the business manager of Intime,
and I directed a bunch of shows at Intime.
I directed Rhinoceros there
and that was a huge experience for me.
These kinds of plays are the plays
that they get me the most excited.
So much of what Cutting Ball's done,
and what I've done in my career,
are absurdist, they're
existential playwrights.
I got a grant from the Fox Foundation
to spend three to four months in Europe
to observe master European directors
working on Shakespeare and translation.
It was such a life-changing experience
and we got really excited by the work
we saw there ... we said "Where can we go
to do this kind of work?"
Rob always says that he explains to people
in the states, we run
an experimental theater company
in San Francisco.
But if we lived in Europe we'd just say
we run a theater company.
We founded the theater together in 1999.
Our mission is to do experimental
new plays, seminal avant garde work,
and re-envision classics.
The joke in the early years
was that Rob was the boss at the theater
and I'm the boss at home. Just this past
season Rob decided to take a sabbatical.
Over the past few years a lot of my focus
has been on directing elsewhere.
I directed a play at Guthrie Theater,
Oregon Shakespeare Festival,
the Public Theater so we switched.
I'm kind of the boss at home.
You are.
Paige is the boss here,
and she's doing a great job.
This piece that I'm working on currently
is Calderon's "Life is a Dream."
A big question for me about the piece
is the jail that Segismundo lives in.
The whole set is a jail and he's
underneath it the whole time.
I officially have a crush on my own set.
I would lay in bed and I couldn't sleep
and I'd think about my sets
and imagine things happening with my set.
We never stop talking about Cutting Ball.
We're on a hike and a kid'll go,
"Look, I got a gecko."
We're like, "Oh, that's amazing. Anyway,
I think the matinee should be ..."
We never, never stop.